it ain't but three things i ain't never
seen a ufo a faithful hoe
and a pink slip to a [ __ ]
all right what is your name diamond d
diamond d
diamond d davin d where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i grew up
in l.a
south central south central l.a tell me
about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young childhood now i was uh
raised up in a single home with just my
mom
and uh we had some rough days you know i
mean
and uh some hungry days but
once i found out about how to get some
money
then i went out on my own at 13.
and i start
started off just by
running around the neighborhood
hollywood uh
inglewood uh
i started hanging around the pimps
and the players because they was the one
getting
the money and they was the one that had
all the girls and i liked the girls you
know i mean
so uh i started hanging with them and
they started
you know schooling me and putting me
putting me in the circle
with the pimps the real pimps uh and
players
so uh
i just took to that and i started liking
the
the the the game you know
i started liking the game and the money
was fast
uh and uh the game was good it was good
to me you know
uh i dropped out of dropped out of
school so i didn't have no education how
far did you go
i think i went to the seventh grade
dropped out of school and uh
i was afraid to break in houses or i
would do anything else so
the next best thing that i knew how to
do was
manipulate manipulate
the females into doing what they needed
to do
in order to put money in my pocket
before i could do what i need to do
and uh from that point you know as i
started to
mature and grow up it all came
together like a puzzle once i had
control
over their mind
everything fell in place um
is that is that the key of the
prostitute relationship is controlling
control control it's not a
bad thing control and management
basically but you you know if you watch
enough of my videos you see
how girl the women are doing things that
are just like
it makes you question like why would you
give away all your money work all night
do dangerous things
because it's amazing all your money
who's sitting back watching it's a
business
it's a business it's one of the oldest
professions around
prostitution but a girl gives you all
the money
all the money and where did she get out
of it whatever she want
i manage i make sure she got a roof i
make sure she eat
i make sure she got nice clothing and
whatever
whatever else she may want in the event
that she may have a drug addiction
i make sure she has that all that
you know opposed to her getting the
money and just going out there giving it
away
and become homeless living on the
streets you know
uh a renegade what we call renegade
renegade holes that every [ __ ]
is after
to try to get take their money rob them
all that
protection so the renegades get get
hassled because they're free
exactly so protection is also by being
with the pimp you're kind of
safer exactly you know because i mean in
in that circle in the pimp game they
respect that
another man's woman unless she decides
to choose another pill
how easy is it how easy for is it for a
girl to go from one pimp to another
i mean it's not that hard i mean
because the game is top locking block
you know you got to accept the losing
like you accepted choosing
but does she have to pay anybody to do
that you know i mean a choosing fee
you know i have a [ __ ] can't come to me
without no money
if you want to be on my team you got to
have a choosing fee
and i got to serve your pimp or whoever
you was with
and let them know this is my this is my
home now
ain't no longer your home and you got to
accept the losing with the choosing
simple as that and how difficult is it
for a girl to get out completely
let's say she wants to live a square
life well you know they got the gorilla
pimps
they won't let them out then they got
the pencils not gorillas don't beat up
bro
i don't put my hands on no female that's
what i don't do
but you got those that will you know
and more or less they're frightened to
leave
or frighten you to to to choosing
someone else or go
uh to another film or to wherever they
might want to go
uh however if
if you got your game in order
and they ain't going nowhere they'll be
with you
you know it's a lot of um
drama in the pim game it's a it's a game
it's a game where
you have to be able to
be versatile you got to be versatile
in order to to stay up stage stay on top
uh and keep your holes in order you got
to keep them in order
you got to have control over this over
their mind
once you have control once you have the
mind you got everything
was that something that came naturally
to you or you learned it came natural
yeah
you know i learned at a young age
that uh when you sex
a hoe you and they world
but when you get in their mind they in
your world
feel me yeah when you get in their mind
they're in your world
but if you sex them
you and they will if you have sex with
them then you and they were yeah
so it's all about control it's all about
control
you know not with just this hair but
with other heads
you got to have control over self
for number one once you can control
yourself you can
control everything in your perimeter how
many girls will you have in your stable
how many have ones i've had six at one
time
i've been six deep you're still active
today you're still active today
yeah that's my number one hoe right
there
she's been around a long time yeah she's
been around she's been with me
for almost 20 years 20 years
20 years yeah you got to be doing
something right yeah
she's the only one that's been faithful
he treats you
to a certain extent to a certain extent
like i told you before
it ain't three things i ain't never seen
a ufo a faithful hoe
and a pink slip to a [ __ ] she's
somewhat faithful
she's been with me yeah but um
yeah so uh right this day and time you
know
i i'm doing some other things i'm doing
some entrepreneur stuff and
you know some intervention for the
youngsters you know i'm saying try to
show them another way to go
you know because uh it's a lot of drama
it's a lot of drama
you know what i'm saying what do you
think most squares don't understand
about
the pimp game what do most squares not
understand about it
that is a business
it's a business when
uh a giant or square
thing is just about uh
leisure or being sexed or whatever
you know so
they don't understand that this is a way
of life
like they go to work and do uh
construction or what have you go to work
too
every day you know this is what pays my
bills
this is what i'm able to put on the
table
this is what take care of my hoes that's
what i do
management you know it's management
and like i said it's a business
it's not just you know a game
it's it's a business you know you ever
been in love before
have i ever been in love i mean i love
her
i ain't never been in love
but i love her what's more important
money your love money
mob you know what m-o-b stands for mlb
money over [ __ ]
yeah hmm you done prison time
yeah i've been to a couple of times
before
uh i've been to the pm for i did white
collar [ __ ]
i've been for uh uh forgery [ __ ] like
that
federal time uh uh
i've been for uh manufacturing
illegal drugs uh
other than that uh i had no pimping and
bannering
you know they called it white or what
they called it used to call it white
slavery
now they called it what human
trafficking
that carries a life sentence yeah the
fines are harsh now
yeah that carries a life sentence seems
much more dangerous than usual yeah it
is
because it's it's you know it's all the
[ __ ] that's going on with the with the
kids
so you got a lot of pedophiles just
selling selling women selling kids
you know what i'm saying i don't agree
to that and what do you think of the new
breed of they're basically gang members
that are
hustling girls as their pimp but they're
not really pimps they're just like gang
members that are pimping them yeah well
she
was she right now a lot of a lot of
youngsters now
they control the hole with dope
with substances you know i mean unless
you get a hole that really love you
you don't have to do all that you just
you know it's
just all about macking and faking
you know show and tell
that's what it's true you know primarily
all about show-and-tell
you know if if i can tell you something
i can show you as well i'm saying
my word is like god in a never returned
void
yeah do you ever have to get physical
with a girl or
intimidate them or are you female yeah i
mean i i've never gotten physical but
i've
had to intimidate them to a certain
point sometime you know
throughout my career you know throughout
my
career i've had to intimidate them you
know and say some things that
may uh uh uh put fear in them
sometimes that's what you had to do you
had to put fear in them like
god like you put fear in god like
that's what it's gonna be and that's all
it is it's going to be like this and
that's
it you know what i mean
uh but as far as physically abusing them
no no no
i've never had to do that i'm not a
guerrilla pimp
i never beat up a woman because
that don't get it you know what i'm
saying that's that's not what it's all
but you got those hoes that like that
and you got to do the pill step that's
what they do that's how they keep them
fear fear
i'm trying to be good and plenty i ain't
trying to put fear in my home
i'm trying to be good give up plenty you
know
so you know that's just the way it is
with me you know that's the school i
come from
the rug i'm cut from you know are the
other girls
in your stable ever you know playing
guys for their money their jewelry their
wallets
oh yeah i've had a few things i had a
few
i had a few that a lot of people don't
understand that that's part of the game
that's part of the game but
you know what they respect that
a trick have to respect that once you do
it the right way i had
i had a hole that would take the rolexes
off a motherfucker's neck
take his money out his wallet and put it
back in his pocket
all in one motion without him knowing
and then
at the end of the day they had to
respect that
because she you know that's just the way
it was
you know and they laugh about it or
whatever you know and they're dead or
again
you know i mean yeah so uh
it's been some you know i've had some
trying times
you know and i've had i've had to check
some
some some some guys about her about my
woman
about my hoes i have to check some of
them because
like i said they don't understand that
it's a business
it's it's not just fun and games there's
some women that are cut out for it and
some that are just not
some are some not some are cut out to be
a whole summer thought out to be
housewives
me personally i don't want nothing but
all
you know what i'm saying i respect the
whole because they're the first thing
lay down
and the last thing they get up
you know and the chances that they take
they never know who they might be with
you feel me
so i understand all that [ __ ]
you know what i mean i never tell them
that
but i understand you know and i
understand the fear that they have when
they step out on that blade
when they step out on their blade
it's fear they got fear it ain't not one
hope
that i've had that i know that didn't
have
fear when she hit the blade hero of what
the tricks might do
exactly exactly
she might not show it she may not shoot
but i'm gonna encourage her that i'm
gonna be there for her
in the event that she needs me i'll be
there
how would you do that let's say i picked
up your young lady here and i
wanted to get crazy and i had a a knife
or a gun or whatever the hell i
how would you know about it once i give
her instructions
as long as she follow my instructions
she'll be okay
but how would she let you know that
there's trouble
with me telephone call
or possibly a a spotter i might have a
spotter following her
just to make sure that she all right
i've heard some of the girls will leave
their phones on for the entire
session that she has with the guy of
course so you can hear everything that's
going on
exactly it's a time limit you know once
that time limit is up
then now it's time to go now it's time
for me to step to the plate
with some of the craziest behavior
you've seen in your years of doing this
you gotta have a story or two right i
had one i had one girl she uh
she turned to date and um
she was gone longer than usual
so anytime they're going you know longer
than usual
then now i'm in question about what's
going on
but i know she has a spot especially if
she's dating in a car
she has a designated place to date that
i know
anything other than that that she's
going to get out the car
if the trick can't go there or she to
the designated spot
then she don't date however
she had a a date and she took a
little longer than normal so i started
to
patrol the perimeter i didn't see the
car
so i hit a corner and i seen her coming
up the street
right she's in the middle of the street
and this dude is following her
so when she see me she come to me right
and uh
my dude took her and uh stabbed her in
the head she's bleeding and [ __ ] right
so i pulled my pistol i said what's
going on she gave me the money and [ __ ]
right
he tell me he said look he said i paid
her but i didn't
get my nut i didn't climax right
she said baby he lying because she had a
condom in her mouth and he didn't know
it
and she pulled it out and she said here
it is right here baby
here it is right here
and uh so i you know i i didn't go
stupid you know what i'm saying i just
kind of
told dude to get on got the [ __ ] on but
he never knew that she had a condom in
her mouth
you know i mean so that was a and then i
had an incident in new york
where one of my girls had uh got a
merchant marine for a money built
and uh they went through a picture of
one doing [ __ ] and
i was crazy you know i mean she went to
jail but she was able to give me the
money bill
before all before she went to jail i
went down building out there
fighting tussling and [ __ ] but anyway uh
i was able to go get her out do you
travel other cities with you girls
i've been i've been around i've been
around this country
i've been to albuquerque i've been to
chicago
i've been to florida uh i've been to
uh utah uh i've been to
arizona and worked all i've had holes
work all those blades
you know uh so i've been around
what do you think the core of the pimp
and prostitute relationship is
is she does she have like a damaged or a
a rough relationship with her father and
then she finds similar treatment with
the tricks and the
pimps no some of the girls do
they have broken homes you know
uh where they've been molested or
you know they feel less than the rest of
the family what have you
if you came from that kind of childhood
this career
with a pimp with the tricks that are
just you know using you
kind of is an adult replacement for them
what do you think of that yeah well you
know uh
sometimes we take advantage of that we
capitalize on that
i do sometimes you know i capitalize on
that i think that's how a female gets
into this correct
exactly you know capitalize on that a
girl with a great father is not going to
no those are the kind of those are the
kind of hoes that's kind of girl we look
for
the broken ones the broken horn one the
broken ones
that's what you look for build them back
up build a self-esteem
and think make them feel that there's
somebody
easy to control easy to control
you know easier to control you know
especially when you give them what their
parents couldn't give them
or you do for them what their parents
didn't do
you know that's what they're looking for
everybody's looking for love
every hoe is looking for love
and that's all you got to show is love
show some love sometimes you got to be
stern though
sometimes you can't show no love you
gotta you got to show tough love
you know you gotta show tough love you
know what i'm saying
an event did she come back without her
quarter you want me to a quarter tonight
you know you got to meet your quarter
if if you're supposed to get 500 if you
go to get a thousand a night
you need not come back in until you have
a thousand how common are drugs
a part of the scene for the girls how
common are the drugs
uh some of them are
is is very common but uh i don't like i
don't i don't i don't like hoes that
use drugs you know because
drugs is a mind-altering substance
and i don't need no hope's mind to be
altered by no drugs
something that can't even talk or
something that's controlling them
rather than me you feel me
so i don't i don't i don't i don't like
dealing with
uh hoes with drug addictions
you know that's that's not good because
like i said
they will control the holes if they get
too many i'm in them
i had hoes run off behind drugs
well you know uh
and i didn't have some hoes that used
drugs
and had to uh let them do what they do
be who they are you feel me
as long as i get what i supposed to get
you know because i got other hoes i got
to take care i got the bills i got to
pay
i got a lot of [ __ ] i got to do man you
know
so it's it's it's common
it's common you know uh because when
they come to a lot of time when they
come to you
they got issues and they're already on
drugs
and they're trying to uh
medicate itself with the drugs
but i'm the doctor i'm the doctor i'm a
medicator
so i don't need you to be on the drugs
i'm the doctor
you feel me yeah so
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing this
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years
the most important lesson i've learned
was the heart was how to control
a person's mind how to control the
whole's mind
that's what's important that was the
lesson to learn
in order to be successful how to control
the mind
first and foremost
once you can control the mind the body
will follow
you know the body is nothing it's the
mind that i'm after
i'm not after the body that the body
gonna follow the mind
feel me yeah
did you have kids
i got a gang of kids
how many how many kids do you think you
got about seven eight
and did you raise them i took care of
them
i took care of them i made sure they
didn't want for nothing
you have some girls yeah how would you
feel if one of your girls was
how would i feel i'm a pimp
ain't no feelings not in that profession
because like i said that's the oldest
profession in the world
one of the oldest you know prostitution
been here
since uh day one
so i mean if that's what she choose to
do
then that's what she do uh
not because i'm a pimple because i get
mine from a hoe
but if that's what she want to do that's
what she do
i'ma steal respect and love her
you know that's i mean hey that's just
the way it is
with me you know um
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story
thank you so much okay very interesting
very interesting
all right mark all right tell me this
yes you're gonna use